[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale a préparé par les équipes de tv
78 nous sort le mercredi 13 avril voici
les titres de cette édition
des coupes sculpté du château de
versailles ont été délocalisées dans les
anciens locaux de l'entreprise
dunlopillo à mantes la jolie un chantier
de restauration qui sera prochainement
ouvert au public pour faire découvrir le
patrimoine ebe noah les trottinettes
électriques sont arrivés sur saint
quentin en yvelines l'année dernière le
bilan dans ce journal un an après le
lancement de l'offre après sky le
service est adoptée par d'autres villes
du département l'exemple de chevreuse
saint rémy les chevreuse et sans cyr
l'école et puis où nos vêtements fini
style leur vie les parties et collectés
et triés par les bornes relais dans les
yvelines ce travail est réalisé à
chanteloup les vignes est découverte du
relais val de seine dans cette édition
[Musique]
et ce sont donc quatre groupes sculptés
du château de versailles qui vont
investir elles les anciens locaux de
l'entreprise dunlopillo située à mantes
la jolie cet espace 2000 440 m²
accueillera le chantier de restauration
en deux ses heures et proposera aux
jeunes une visite pour découvrir le
patrimoine yvelinois dans le même temps
cet endroit deviendra un tir le le
premier dans les yvelines le reportage
de célia gars tsongo cet acte et
conventions signées entre les
départements des yvelines et le château
de versailles pour la mise en place du
chantier de restauration de quatre
groupes sculptés sur l'ancienne friche
du site industriel dunlopillo située à
mantes la jolie pour l'instant de son
surplace découpé en 85 palette elle
trônait normalement sur les piliers des
grilles de l'orangerie du château de
versailles la restauration va durer
environ 18 mois en septembre prochain
cet espace sera ouvert aux visiteurs un
jour par semaine on va montrer ce
travail aux habitants de mantes-la-jolie
aux jeunes qui pourront venir à la fois
voir ce que sont ces métiers le voir en
temps réel ce pouvoir même s'exercer à
ce travail et puis comprendre
l'importance que ak ce patrimoine non
pas par rapport au passé mais par
rapport à l'avenir avant l'ouverture
tout public une première opération aura
lieu cet été auprès des jeunes issus des
quartiers politique de la ville et de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance dans le cadre
de l'été royal entre juillet et août ce
seront trois mille jeunes à peu près
entre 6 ans et 18 ans donc avec des
ateliers prévus pour eux est adapté à ce
qu'il à l'orage notamment et bien qu'ils
pourront venir ici découvrir ses travaux
autour de la pierre et puis ensuite
venir découvrir le château versailles
lors de la signature de la convention le
département des yvelines a officialisé
la création d'un tiers lieux culturels
sur le site de lusine dunlopillo fermé
depuis 2020 diverses associations
orienté cultures urbaines comme le graff
le breakdance ou encore la glisse
urbaine était présente pour donner un
avant goût de ce que va devenir cet
espace 2000 440 m² il faut que d'avoir
une espèce de friches gardienne ou alors
aux comptes démolissent tous les
bâtiments et connaît un espace vide
absolument pas de l'amour ha
et sans usage ça serait vraiment dommage
et ça va être le premier tiers lieux
anil de franches
en grande couronne un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt va donc être
lancée en attendant le bâtiment et ses
abords sont en cours de rénovation
coût total des travaux estimé à un peu
moins d'un million d'euros
jusqu'au 23 avril prochain les archives
départementales des yvelines organise un
nouveau concours au numérique ouvert à
tous l énigme la dame aux faucons elle
sous forme d'une enquête à résoudre les
participants plongeront dans des
documents d'archivés à la recherche de
jeanne guinard archéologues on en parle
avec mathilde d'oeuvre chargé de
développement des publics des archives
départementales à daisy bus était au
micro de célia 400 go
clé nîmes est un concours qui est ouvert
à tous
et c'est un concours numérique donc
comme en fait les énigmes sont à sont à
résoudre exclusivement en ligne sur le
site internet des archives et donc il
s'agit d'un parcours avec une série de
deux petites enquêtes une série de
petites questions qu'il va falloir
résoudre en allant chercher et en
consultant des documents d'archivés dans
ce concours en fait il y a deux
catégories vous avez une catégorie quand
son public qui est ouverte donc vraiment
à tout voir résidente en france et une
catégorie spécifique pour les collégiens
des yvelines
[Musique]
cette année on s'est focalisé vraiment
sûr sur le moyen-âge et cette fameuse
dame au fond on monte il va falloir
retrouver l'identité on va sur la trace
de personnages qui ont réellement existé
et donc pouvait justement l'histoire et
la mémoire dans les documents des
archives
[Musique]
le groupe a récompensé
30 joueurs grand public et 30 joueurs
collégiens on va voir gagner des
tablettes des ordinateurs des drones
[Musique]
et je vous le disais en titre après les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
d'autres villes ont décidé d'adopter la
trottinette électrique à chevreux et
saint rémy les chevreuse par exemple une
expérimentation est en cours c'est un
reportage de bixente mais rien senti
steban
leur absence des stations est une marque
de succès une centaine de trottinettes
électriques et 35 stations sont en
expérimentation à saint rémy les
chevreuse et chevreuse un complément aux
autres mobilité comme le train le bus et
le transport à la demande
c'est plus économique que les autres
moins de transport c'est beaucoup plus
écologique et en plus ces
demandes et fort par donc un vélo a mise
à disposition comme un vélib du coup je
pense vraiment que c'est un mode de
transport qui est adapté peut-être bien
mais moi je vu mon âge
c'est pas quelque chose je prendrais pas
mais bon
pour les jeunes chez très bien à
l'origine une demande des habitants du
plateau de saint rémy et de magny les
hameaux communes voisines afin de
faciliter l'accès à la gare rer de saint
rémy on a pensé que effectivement ça
pourrait permettre de combler un petit
peu ce manque de mobilité pour le
dernier kilomètre ce qu'on appelle
toujours le dernier kilomètre quand on
arrive de soi de son travail soit pour
aller de son travail à son domicile de
son domicile à une activité et qu'elle
soit sportive
de formation ou autre c'est lié une
démarche aussi environnemental de
facilités de déplacement de
d'intermodalité avec tous les modes
moyen de transport et je pense qu'il
faut rien s'interdire aujourd'hui une
alternative à la voiture qui rend
pourtant certains habitants sceptique je
suis assez assez assez
inquiet sur le fait qu'on les lectrices
beaucoup de choses et donc ça veut dire
plus de batterie et plus de terreur fait
des choses dont on parle beaucoup en ce
moment et je sais une dérive qui ne me
plaît pas du tout voilà vouloir une
trottinette à l'ancienne voilà je peux
encore vous bouger un peu mes pieds pour
pour lüthi voilà sans motorisation 100
sont quoi que ce soit l'expérimentation
supervisé par l'entreprise tire mobility
va se poursuivre durant les mois à venir
en cas de réussite auprès des habitants
et de modèle économique viable le
service sera définitivement adoptée
après l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines les trottinettes électriques
sont adoptées par d'autres villes du
département on vient de voir les
exemples avec chevreuse et saint rémy
les chevreuse dans ce reportage il y a
également des trottinettes électriques
qui vont être déployés à saint cyr
l'école ou 23 stations seront en service
ce sera à partir du 19 avril prochain
une offre proposée par l'opérateur tiers
mobility il sera compatible donc avec le
réseau déployé sur saint quentin en
yvelines l'année dernière et donc des
stations correspondantes dans les 12
communes de l'agglomération
et justement pour continuer sur le sujet
jean baptiste est amené que vous êtes
avec nous vos phares pour soir donc je
le rappelle vous êtes vice président
délégué aux transports et mobilité
durables de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
vous êtes donc avec nous justement pour
parler à des trottinettes et de ce
projet ça fait un an donc que les
trottinettes électriques sont arrivés
sur saint quentin en yvelines on va
faire le bilan à dans un instinct avec
vous mais juste avant cela on va parler
justement de cette extension de l'offre
déjà disponible donc sur sky mais à
présent qui s'étend au delà de
l'agglomération comme on vient de le
voir qu'est ce que vous pensez vous de
cette extension est en fait finalement
comment vous l'expliquez alors déjà je
trouve que c'est une excellente chose je
pense que on a tous été au départ un peu
réfractaires à l'idée d'aller sur cette
mobilité qu'est la trottinette puisqu'on
avait les jia quelques années un peu
anarchique notamment sur les grandes
métropoles comme paris et puis on a eu
la loi l'homme la loi d'orientation des
mobilités et puis un cadre législatif et
réglementaire qui est venu encadrer l
usage de cette nouvelle mobilité qui je
le rappelle est soumise au code de la
route et sur saint quentin en yvelines
nous avons mené la première
expérimentation en territoire périurbain
et je crois que c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui quelque part qu'on fait des
petits et que certaines collectivités
j'en suis ravi nous emboîtent le pas
c'est parce que en tout cas les
conclusions le bilan de nos premiers
mois presque un an d'exploitation sont
très positifs fierté un petit peu
d'avoir été le pilote de tout ça
finalement 50 ans directeur d'une région
comme on dit exactement un dock on le
sait cette trottinette donc ce sont
c'est une offre de transport
complémentaire on disait même si ce
déploiement se fait finalement en dehors
de l'agglomération
il pourra profiter aux saint quentinois
puisqu'on l'a vu notamment je parle des
exemples qu'on a vu dans le reportage
mais pour se rendre par exemple
facilement rer b à saint rémy les
chevreuse ou encore prochainement au
tram 13 à saint cyr l'école donc ça
étant finalement la possibilité de
déplacement même pour les saint
quentinois et oui tout à fait la logique
et c'est la même que pour le vélo
finalement quand on a réfléchi dans
notre schéma directeur cyclable sur
l'agglomération évidemment qu'on s'est
pas arrêté aux frontières de
l'agglomération on a travaillé avec les
aux intercommunalités pour qu'ils aient
des continuités donc si on peut avoir
demain et dans les prochains mois des
continuités avec d'autres communes du
territoire départemental c'est très bien
moi je le vois à villepreux saint cyr
c'est à côté si on peut avoir des
liaisons et si on peut avoir
effectivement un service qui s'étale sur
l'ensemble des communes et sur
l'ensemble du territoire ça va être
bénéfique pour les déplacements est-ce
que vous justement vous voulez mis en
place on l'a dit la dernière mais est-ce
que vous travaillez encore avec
l'opérateur pour cible et justement des
vies clé en termes de déplacements pour
les saint quentinois oui alors moi je
suis assez sollicités par l'opérateur au
titre de mes délégations à saint quentin
et je suis intervenu lors du salon
autonomie à paris aussi pour faire la
promotion quelque part de cet opérateur
puisque il a coché tous les critères que
nous avions lors de l'appel à
candidatures et que nous sommes
aujourd'hui très satisfaits et
finalement vous le voyez les
collectivités que ce soit des communes
en propre des intercommunalités qui nous
emboîtent peux pas et je vais pas
dévoiler de secrets mais je sais que
d'autres vont suivre parts sur le même
opérateur que celui retenu par saint
quentin en yvelines parce que je pense
que notre cahier des charges étaient
bons et parce qu'aujourd'hui l'opérateur
avec qui nous sommes en lien au
quotidien finalement nous offre des
garanties et travaille avec sérieux sur
le terrain et parce qu'elle sera aussi
compatible j'imagine tout à fait tout à
fait y aurait une comptabilité une
compatibilité effectivement du coût des
engins et du service sur le territoire
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué notamment
pour les aspects tarifaires si vous avez
plusieurs opérateurs sur un territoire
donné donc aujourd'hui si ces tirs
aujourd'hui enfin demain à saint cyr à
saint-rémy et peut-être ailleurs ça
facilite aussi le parcours de
l'utilisateur qui n'aura pas besoin de
changer d'engins qui n'aura pas besoin
d'avoir de multiples comptes chez
plusieurs opérateurs de trottinettes
donc et d'avoir d'ailleurs plusieurs
abonnements puisque comme nous offrons
aussi avec tir des abonnements ça va
permettre d'avoir un rayonnement plus
large sur l'ensemble du territoire donc
une bonne chose finalement cette
extension on va passer un peu une partie
bilan puisque vous vous lavez développer
sur saint quentin en yvelines c'était le
7 mai dernier 2021 ça a été lancé vous
étiez pilotes on l'a dit tout à l'heure
quel bilan vous tirer après cette
première année d'expérimentation sur
certains c'est un bilan qui est positif
même très positif à plusieurs à
plusieurs niveaux d'abord je rappelle et
c'est peut-être aussi le message que
j'adresse à mes collègues qui lancent
l'opération
en ce moment même où dans les prochaines
qui vont le faire dans les prochaines
semaines il ya toujours une mise en
service et une prise en compte de ce
changement comme tout changement faut
l'accompagner qui va entraîner des
petites difficultés au départ c'est
normal il faut que le service entre dans
les moeurs donc nous on a eu trois
semaines un peu délicate il faut le dire
puisque c'était une nouvelle mobilité
qu'il fallait l'appréhender qu'au début
en plus il y avait des offres
promotionnelles donc
on avait aussi beaucoup de jeunes qui
ont testé on va dire un peu la
robustesse des services mais finalement
passer cette phase là on voit que le
contrat est rempli dans le sens où notre
coeur de cible était les jeunes
travailleurs les salariés du territoire
les étudiants et finalement quand on
regarde les tranches d'âge on voit
globalement que de 18 à 45 50 ans on
touche notre coeur de cible avec avec
effectivement un nombre de trajets
important on est à plus de 600000 trajet
sur le territoire ça fait quarante mille
usagers ça fait près dans saint
quentinois sur sur cinq qui ce qu'ils
utilisent aujourd'hui la trottinette
électrique et là où aussi ou sur le
bilan c'est très positif c'est que nous
avions ciblé cette mobilité comme étant
une mobilité complémentaires et
alternatifs parfois sur ce qu'on appelle
le premier et dernier kilomètre d'un
trajet domicile travail hélas le contrat
est rempli et puis avec une enquête
utilisateurs qui nous offre en tout cas
débouche aujourd'hui sur un niveau de
satisfaction de d'une note de plus de 4
sur 5 donc quatre usagers sur cinq sont
soient satisfaits soit très satisfait là
vous vous parliez justement aussi du
public avisé finalement est ce que tous
les saint quentinois se sont approprié
le service manquant il y à des actes
peut-être encore d'amélioration ou
comment ça se passe alors je vais vous
dresser le portrait robot de
l'utilisateur type enfin l'utilisateur
type il a à 72% c'est c'est un homme de
moins de 35 ans 72 % des utilisateurs
sont des hommes ce qui veut dire qu'on a
encore un public féminin à aller
chercher donc il faut qu'on travaille
sur ça clairement nous allons pas
travailler sur la tranche des plus de 65
ans qui n'utilisent pas les trottinettes
mais qui ne le feront pas demain mais ce
n'est pas le public que nous ciblons et
puis peut-être aussi sur le public
lycéen parce que je pense à tous ces
jeunes entre 16 et 18 ans on n'a pas
envie d'aller en dessous de 16 ans mais
entre 16 et 18 ans vous avez un public
jeunes notamment qui n'est pas véhiculer
qu'il n'a pas nécessairement le permis
de conduire et on voit que la
trottinette est aussi une alternative
pour les déplacements courts au sein
même d'une ville pour rejoindre un
gymnase pour rejoindre un commerce pour
rejoindre une école donc on veut
travailler sur ça et l'autre motif de
satisfaction puisqu'il ya quand même un
côté écologique et une empreinte carbone
a diminué ses convois dans notre enquête
que 27 % des utilisateurs optent pour la
trottinette aujourd'hui plutôt que le
véhicule c'est à dire que quand on veut
aller à une gare ferroviaire ou une gare
routière pour aller chercher le bus ou
le train et bien finalement on
privilégie la trottinette alors
peut-être pas aujourd'hui parce que le
temps est pas formidable mais en
préférant privilégier aujourd'hui la
trottinette à la voiture et donc ça
aussi pour le développement durable
c'est plutôt une bonne chose et
peut-être en termes de chiffres vous a
déjà parlé du nombre d'abonnés et tout
ça mais peut-être en termes de chiffres
on en est où aujourd'hui en termes de
trottinettes de stations quelle est la
suite finalement pas que nous étions sur
une expérimentation qui va toucher à son
terme on a décidé de partir sur 300
stations et une flotte de mille engins
donc ça fonctionne très bien ça nous
permet aujourd'hui de voir quelles sont
les stations qui ont le mieux fonctionné
clairement c'est celle à proximité des
gares et des transports en commun et
puis de voir les stations qu'ils auront
peut-être moins fonctionné ou qu'ils ont
raison de la localité de l'emplacement
mériterait d'être adapté donc demain ce
qui va se passer c'est qu'il va y avoir
à peu près 10% du parc actuel des 300
stations qui vont être réajustés et puis
on va monter en puissance puisque
aujourd'hui les douze maires de
l'agglomération veulent poursuivre on
est tous très satisfaits du service et
nos administrés aussi donc plus de
stations demain et plus d'engins j'ai
pas de nombre j'ai pas de l'identité à
donner mais en tout cas avec l'opérateur
tire on a décidé
de poursuivre et de poursuivre encore
plus vite et plus fort donc il y aura
une suite plus fortes comme il y aura
une suite évidemment on l'espérer et
cette fois ci elle est confirmée merci
beaucoup jean baptiste à monique et
blabla était avec nous et je le rappelle
vous êtes vice président délégué aux
transports et aux mobilités et durable
de saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
savez vous où vos vêtements finissent
leur vie si 81% sont jetés aux ordures
ménagères le restant est collectés et
triés par les bornes relais et dont les
yvelines elles sont tout centraliser à
chanteloup-les-vignes matip de franck où
vous fait découvrir le relais val de
seine vous avez sans doute déjà vu ces
bornes dans votre ville peut-être même
les avez vous déjà utilisé pour donner
des habits des sacs des chaussures mais
savez vous comment les vêtements sont
ensuite triés et réutilisées par la
suite partons ensemble à la découverte
des coulisses du relais val-de-seine de
chanteloup les vignes
[Musique]
chaque matin les chauffeurs du relais
par à 6h30 et sillonne les yvelines pour
récolter les sacs de vêtements dans les
bornes en très près chaque jour 22 tomes
de vêtements donc c'est tout un procès
ce qui est mise en place et donc moi je
pilote l'activité donc les 22 tante qui
vont rentrer avant de voir elle rentre
de manière brute original et elles vont
devoir ressortir tout trier selon une
cinquantaine de catégories les
vidéophages aussi c'est une catégorie de
la finale dont les particulièrement fier
j'en ai fait ce sont les vieux jeans
pour fabriquer jones fn le métis
quand même donné aux vêtements une
seconde vie à ses
ventes en outre la collecte et le tri
des vêtements le rené val de seine est
avant tout une entreprise à but
socio-économique
c'est à dire qu'elle ne recherche pas la
performance économique pour le profit
mais pour atteindre des objectifs
sociaux chaque centime est générée est
réinvesti à des fins de lutte contre
l'exclusion est un sucre aqueuse alors
le titre accuse c'est simple c'est quand
les chauffeurs et ramène les sacs
classiques de vêtements je dois les
cracks est ok en triant de maisons l'eau
les blousons
les chaussures et les j'ouvrais enfants
et le reste servant sur le tapis ces
défis qui tri parmi les 140 personnes
qui travaillent relèvent elles de seine
90 sont en insertion pour un contrat de
deux ans aujourd'hui la plus de la
moitié des enfants sont des emplois donc
pour l'insertion ça veut dire que ça
permet des personnes éloignées de
l'emploi
deux seront professionnaliser aux
professionnels et aux cours et de
retrouver l'emploi par la suite en
france chaque année 80 % des vêtements
finissent leur vie aux ordures ménagères
en donnant vos avis vos chaussures ou
votre linge de maison vous faites ainsi
un geste écologique mais aussi solidaire
en trente ans le relais à créer plus de
2200 emplois et intervient sur
l'ensemble du territoire français
en politique à présent le deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle arrive à
grands pas le scooter du 24 avril verra
élire un ou une chef de l'état pour les
cinq ans à venir a dans ce cadre et tout
au long de la semaine le collectif elle
les surligneurs décortique pour vous le
rôle du président de la république et ce
mercredi raphaël mata duvignau elle nous
explique les pouvoirs qui lui sont
conférés
dans cette chronique regarder la
constitution confère au président de la
république des pouvoirs étendus il
veille au respect de la constitution
s'assure du fonctionnement régulier des
pouvoirs publics et de la conduite et de
l'état il est le garant également de
l'indépendance nationale de l'intégrité
du territoire et du respect des traités
de manière générale il défend les
intérêts essentiels de l'état à
l'intérieur et internationale c'est une
puissance tutélaire susceptibles de
modeler son intervention en fonction des
circonstances il détient ainsi ce qu'on
appelle le pouvoir d'état et en tant que
garant de l'unité nationale et les
intérêts vitaux de la nation il pourrait
ne pas tenir compte de considérations
seulement juridique mais aussi se
fondait sont des raisons d'opportunité
au nom de l'intérêt social du pays le
président de la république détient des
pouvoirs propres c'est-à-dire sans
contre 5 ministériel par exemple la
nomination du premier ministre ou de
membres du conseil constitutionnel la
saisine de ce dernier pour le contrôle
de constitutionnalité des lois
la mise en oeuvre des pouvoirs
exceptionnels de crise la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale le droit de
message devant les parlementaires
la décision d'organiser un référendum
législatif ou encore l'emploi de la
force nucléaire
d'autres pouvoirs nécessite le
contreseing du premier ministre et des
ministres concernés ceci étant
mécanismes classiques du régime
parlementaire donc par exemple la
nomination des ministres ou à certains
aux emplois civils et militaires de
l'état la signature des ordonnances et
décrets délibéré en conseil des
ministres la convocation du parlement en
session extraordinaire
la décision d'organiser des référendums
de révision constitutionnelle ou de
ratification d'un traité
permettant l'adhésion d'un nouvel état à
l'union européenne ou encore la
promulgation des lois la constitution
dispose enfin que le président et le
chef des armées et négocie et ratifie
les traités la pratique institutionnelle
fait de ces matières un domaine réservé
au chef de l'état sa prééminence étant
reconnu s'il peut décider de l'emploi
des forces armées notamment d'opérations
extérieures il ne peut toutefois pas
déclaré la guerre puisque l'autorisation
du parlement est nécessaire
plus que le texte constitutionnel est
davantage la pratique du pouvoir qui a
rendu le rôle du chef de l'état aussi
important
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi dans un instant vous
retrouverez votre magazine société
présentée par mélanie poquet thème de la
soirée la restauration du patrimoine
dans les yvelines très bonne soirée à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]
il